salvador dali hospitalisé la nuit
dernière il souffre de brûlures il y
avait eu un début d'incendié dans sa
chambre du château de pujols près de
barcelone
mais surtout le grand peintre était déjà
en très mauvaise santé il souffrait de
dénutrition
pascal guimier dans cet hymne usine noir
le marquis de pub hall prostré sur la
banquette arrière
le marquis bol c'est le grand peintre
surréaliste salvador dali hier au milieu
de la nuit le maître et conduit
d'urgence dans un hôpital de barcelone
daly est brûlé au second degré à la
jambe droite et à l'abdomen
c'est un feu de cheminée qui s'est
déclaré dans sa chambre alors qu'il
dormait un instant on a même craint pour
sa vie
dalli a 80 ans depuis la perte de sa
compagne gala il ya deux ans le maître
c'est pratiquement cloîtré dans son
château de pubol il a fallu cet accident
pour qu'on arrache à son isolement
volontaire
atteint de la maladie de parkinson
souffrons de dénutrition chronique
salvador dali devrait être nourri par
voie intraveineuse